pop
puis c'est en rachetant d'hachette
acheter pour acheter oui oui
[Musique]
après 10 heures
art de faire mieux
jamais
le changement d'époque prix normal c'est
pour embêter
200 vols jamais vu ça une demi livre de
beurre un paquet margarine un grand pot
de crème moins cher que vous avez
nautique sur un centre du milieu
moi j'ai pas tellement trouvé que ça va
augmenter ensuite instruments le poireau
à 140 pour la gauche je suis fâché non
non non
des quantités croissantes il fut témoin
qui a été plus maligne à 200 pour la
boîte us et la saison pendant ma n'avons
pas été payés au monde savait pas qu'ils
sachent était quand même 14 40
vous avez oui pour ça va cadrer temps
reviendra bien alors ils sont tous en la
pharmacie vous avez l'air de faire du
coach très sérieusement et vous savez
que les prix augmentent ou diminuent à
l'écouté je suis allée course
traditionnellement alors je peux pas
dire je sais par ma femme voilée
brièvement et vous monsieur vous croyez
qu'il ait pris roman tout cas les prix
diminuent je vois des jeux vidéo
on est à quelques mois alors madame
trail est il écrit durement tout le
fruit du min
c'est par exemple une femme souffrante
différence depuis deux mois il ya eu des
augmentations dans des choses qu'ils
n'auraient pas dû à voter par exemple
tel que le savon en taille avec par
exemple voyez vous eh bien je trouve que
c'est anormal savons payet je vais vous
dire vous avez des boîtes pour 2 francs
50 c'est une onde de payer sa de francs
50 c'est rien du tout avec évidemment
sur les 250 vous avez déjà plus d'un
franc 25 de publicité la situation et
qu'elle choque moi qui ai d'augmentation
réelle à l'heure actuelle je ne sais pas
si on aura ou alors allez peut-être
insidieuse support de 3 centimes sur le
sucre à 100 qui nous sur mes ennuis
[Musique]
ça dépend des formes de commerce aussi
bien qu'il fait 19,50 diminue diminue dû
à quoi
bondues savez c'est assez délicat une
dizaine de fois pardon madame je sentais
que le crillon magasin par exemple des
magasins vous déclencherez les prix ont
seulement ces derniers me faire appeler
mon père je veux quitter l'hôpital par
exemple vous trouvez à 39 ans dans un
temps fou je prendrais ça ou 55 cents à
mon métier par exemple je suivais à
faire l'autre jour il ya quelques jours
à monsieur qui était qui produisait de
l'apprendre de terre qui était vendu je
crois de la belle de fontenay qui
étaient vendus par exemple 15 30 kg oil
qui étaient revendus 30 à 35 francs par
les mandataires oil et je la vois
aujourd'hui sur le marché à 125 francs
le kilo c'est précis comment voyez-vous
monsieur que la roue de gruyère même
dans des succursales multiples pour la
coupe en duo lambin une moitié au bout
du comptoir une moitié de l'autre côté
avec sais pas combien de différence au
kilo et c'est la moitié qui les prières
qui s'en va la première c'est qu'à la
bêtise humaine
by guillaume angué deux minutes à l'aide
d'observations pour nos partenaires et
moi je m'aperçois que ça monte tellement
ils sont en ruines où je vous de même le
poisson avant c'était le poisson s'était
joué les familles ouvriers s'étaient
abanda mais alors maintenant alors de
plus mon mari chômeur troisième option à
percevoir ou avant pâques et sig a dit
aux 200 balles je les payais à son
enfant il vaut 200 balles je l'achète
l'état aussi commerçant s'il ya eu la
vignette de la vignette ya il ya eu des
super hard et puis je vais décideurs
dans le bois de l'ordinaire voulait pas
remarqué des papiers au moment où les
transports ont augmenté chez chaque
bonbon les commerçants qui peut le
prendre à leur charge fait pas tout
si les transports sncf augmente ce
serait bien étonnant ce les transports
ok saliba alors certainement incident
qui s'en sort avant payer une assurance
volontaire maladie vous savez je faisais
volontaires ont payé 60 mille francs
et maintenant c'est pas c'est
obligatoire sous peine d'amendé puis on
vous rappelle eh bien on vous fait payer
maintenant 140 mille francs donc on est
encore 90 francs tu vois encore
ressortir au supplément la tva qui était
de 20 c 23 46 maintenant obligé de
mentir il ne le récupère et pendant
récolte il ya des commerçants qui
peuvent le récupérer mais on peut pas le
récupérer et oui oui 6 non interdites
pendant le mois de décembre janvier
on voudrait arriver sur les clients face
à pauli chez les commerçants et bien ça
c'est pas possible c'est pas qu'on
pouvait pas dire un run à boucher ça ne
marche pas la police s'est pas sakho
fait faux pas des robots
bush et où vous achetez trop chez vous
nous vendez trop cher c'est ne pas lui
acheter
c'est tout la police c'est ça que vous
allez lui sert même pas dû tomber dessus
des savoises de contrôle des prix a rien
c'est revenir on le voit jamais on n'en
voit jamais et pas qu'ils sont 800 pour
toute la france
c'est tout à fait insuffisant reprenez
[Musique]